two-time nominee for your first feature
is incredible you know what this morning
I was with all these gentlemen on a like
a conference and it was you know just to
be there and talk about movies and talks
about the work is this dream to be there
with Spike Lee all about it too as you
guys are both first-time nominees I will
agree with that I will also agree with
that I really really was rooting for you
to get the directing nomination for the
Oscar everything else is wonderful but
you really deserved it
but speaking of the Oscars we now know
that you will be singing at the Oscars
how prepared are you yeah but I didn't
have any preparation you know that was
just to see that was that was that was
an amazing experience but but no I want
to work and you know like rehearse like
two days before I had thought about it
and and called maybe I go to the show
and then I knew that she was saying
shallow for her finale
I don't know maybe if she wants to bring
me up and let's see if it's not
horrendous so what does the preparation
for the Oscars sound like I mean doing
like vocal warm-ups yeah I mean I worked
with this guy Roger love you know I
couldn't sing before this movie and so
in terms of being able to sing in front
of people I'm you know it's it's very
nerve-wracking it's not easy what they
do mom coming this year I will see
you